(звучить пісня)
"Змін просять наші серця…" Цей перебудовний хіт Віктора Цоя
став неофіційним гімном протестів у Білорусі.
Цілий світ облетіли кадри, як співробітники білоруських спецслужб
намагаються завадити діджеям програти цю пісню на передвиборчому концерті.
Змін хоче не лише народ Білорусі. Змін в "останній диктатурі Європи"
чекають і європейські політики.
Вибори не були ані чесними, ані вільними,
тому результати цих виборів не можна визнати.
Ми бачимо репресії, порушення прав людини, є жертви, поранені.
Єдиним мирним вирішенням нинішньої кризи в Білорусі
є повторне проведення виборів у присутності міжнародних місій спостерігачів.
Очевидно, що режиму Білорусі настає кінець.
Лідери країн ЄС перервали свою літню відпустку,
аби надіслати чіткий сигнал підтримки білорусам. Євросоюз продемонстрував
тверду позицію, ставши на бік опозиції у Білорусі.
Європа відмовилася визнати Олександра Лукашенка переможцем президентських виборів.
При цьому закликала білоруську владу шляхом діалогу шукати вихід із кризи.
Саме про це просила опозиція.
Разом із тим Брюссель готує персональні санкції проти осіб,
винних у насильстві, придушенні протестів та фальсифікації виборів.
Європейські оглядачі підкреслюють, що з точки зору демократії
це єдино можлива відповідь на брутальне поводження білоруської влади з демонстрантами.
З іншого боку, вони вбачають у цьому і деякі ризики.
Мовляв, статус "нелегітимного" розв'язує Лукашенку руки в приборканні протестів,
що він, власне, і почав демонструвати.
Вже після відеосаміту ЄС Лукашенко наказав своїм силовикам "присікти" масові безлади,
як він називає мітинги опозиції, а білоруському МЗС доручив
попередити лідерів західних країн про відповідальність за розпалювання протестів,
які, на його думку, фінансуються з-за кордону.
Спробу німецької канцлерки Анґели Меркель
поговорити з ним телефоном Лукашенко проігнорував.
Керівники західних держав пропонують нам переговори, розмови,
а в цей час продовжують гнути свою лінію.
Я би порадив їм, перш ніж тицяти пальцем у нас,
внести у порядок денний своїх нарад питання жовтих жилетів, наприклад, у Франції,
жахливих безладів у Сполучених Штатах Америки. Я б хотів, аби вони
розглянули у першу чергу протести проти коронавірусної ізоляції у Німеччині,
інших країнах Європи… Мені здається, що у цих панів колода в оці.
Хоробрості Лукашенку, переконані аналітики, додає насамперед підтримка Кремля.
Саме через це, на їхню думку, Євросоюз поки зважився
лише на персональні санкції для низки можновладців.
На масштабніший тиск Європа не наважується,
адже існують побоювання, що надто відверта підтримка
опонентів Лукашенка Європою спровокує втручання Росії.
У Брюсселі бояться повторення українського сценарію 2014 року,
коли Москва скористалася політичною напругою як приводом для військової агресії.
Москва, у свою чергу, теж боїться нових санкцій, вважають у Брюсселі:
Лукашенко не дав Путіну того, що він хотів від Білорусі,
тому я не бачу аж надто багато причин для росіян втручатися,
ризикуючи наразитися заради Лукашенка на подальші соціально-економічні труднощі,
від яких вони і так вже потерпають. Їм не потрібні нові проблеми з Заходом,
а надто - з білоруським суспільством.
На тлі продовження хвилі протестів у Білорусі було створено Координаційну раду опозиції.
До неї, серед іншого, увійшла нобелевська лауреатка Світлана Алєксієвич.
Рада ухвалила резолюцію з вимогою до влади
негайно розпочати переговори для оголошення нових виборів,
однак Лукашенко лише пригрозив опозиціонерам покаранням за "захоплення влади".
Символічні санкції ЄС Лукашенка поки не налякали.
Оглядачі кажуть, що борцям за демократію в Білорусі
варто більше розраховувати на власні сили і сподіватися,
що Лукашенко, в силу різних причин, погодиться на діалог замість арештів,
кийків та гумових куль. Скептики побоюються, що ізоляція Заходу
підштовхне Лукашенка в обійми Москви. Якщо навіть Кремль утримається
від скерування до Білорусі "зелених чоловічків", він може
надати у розпорядження Лукашенку інші інструменти, приміром,
фінансову підтримку та свою пропагандистську машину.